[Music]
Mary Stewart is condemned to death by
order of our sovereign Elizabeth Queen
of England how did it come to this there
is news King Francis is dead
your cousin Mary has returned to rule in
Scotland she is formidable madam so she
comes ready for war not so I need
command armies but tell my cousin that
we pray for peace
I hope we might meet in person
and resolve our destinies you must
confront the truth Madame
she has acclaimed your throne
you would have made a poster system on
it is either civil war there what civil
war here we have a scourge upon our land
the woman with a crappy what says her
brother because allegiance is fully with
us
there's no appetite for war and let a
stubborn appetite
oh cool men are all I have done it's
tried to unify this land that they are
trying to use her my crime a murderer a
traitor and to Queen but I will be the
woman she is not we bring into this
world and here to Scotland and to
England
don't you know in it if you speak if it
21 I shall tonight be my boys got
another B my sister Mary is our first we
ask that we never bow to her as we bow
before you you cannot raise an army many
times you have said I cannot do what I
have done
do not play into their home your heart
has more within it than the men who
can't believe they would do well to
watch over I will not be scolded by my
inferior
if you Martin you murder your sister and
you murder your queen
I didn't come to this
[Music]
you